هل لاحظتم عدم وصول بعض ما تنشرونه مؤخرا
الى
متابعيكم بالتزامن مع المعارك على الارض
تجري معركه من نوع اخر منصات التواصل
المتهمه بانحيازها الدائم للقيم الغربيه
قررت ان تكون طرفا فيها وهذا الامر ليس
بجديد راينا مثلا كيف اتهمت بالانحياز
لاوكرانيا عندما شنت روسيا حربا عليها
وللحكومة الروهينجيا والامثله كثيره خلال
الايام الماضيه اتسعت حمله اغلاق الحسابات
خاصه الداعمه للقضيه الفلسطينيه من بينها
صفحات كبيره ومعروفه كما قيدت مئات الاف
المنشورات حسابات الجزيره على منصات
التواصل كانت عرضه لهذه الاجراءات رغم
التزامها التام بالمعايير المحدده لكن
للخوارزميات المنحاز راي اخر فهل توجد اي
اجراءات تساعد في تجاوز هذا الحظر اي شخص
ينشر فلسطين حره على الانترنت فهو معاد
للساميه رصدنا نصائح منتشره تقترح طرقا
لتجاوز او لنقل لتضليل هذه الخوارزميات
البعض يقول ان التلاعب بالاحرف قد يفيد
للتمويه عن الكلمات المحظوره لكن هذه
الطريقه قد لا تاتي بنتائج مضمونه وهناك
من ينصح بعدم استخدام الهاشتاجات المعروفه
والمرتبطه بما يجري وينصح باستخدام اخرى
لا علاقه لها بالموضوع كما الامكان تعديل
الاعدادات المتعلقه بتصنيف المحتوى الحساس
الذي هو في الغالب يتعلق بما يجري اخرون
يقولون ان نشر صور لا علاقه لها بالقضيه
التي تهتم بها من حين لاخر قد يعزز فرص
انتشار المحتوى المعرض للحجم واخيرا وليس
اخرا التفاعل اكثر مع كل ما ينشر حول هذه
القضيه